die hoffnung ist groß wird die trauer
die royale familie endlich einen die
zerstrittenen brüder william und harry
endlich wieder zusammenbringen alles
guckt natürlich auch zwei frauen auf
kate auf der einen seite und medien auf
der anderen bisher nicht best fans würde
ich mal vorsichtig sagen wir haben die
fäden dabei in der hand und kämpfen
gleichzeitig darum die neue königin der
herzen zu werden
ein blumenmeer vor schloss windsor ein
königreichen trauer diese vereint sogar
kate william harry und megan eigentlich
seit jahren zerstritten am samstag
kommen sie zum ersten mal seit dem exit
zusammen legen blumen ab gedenken der
verstorbenen queen bilder wie diese sie
erinnern an den sommer 1997 damals eher
ein blumen ozean vor dem kensington
palace in dem sommer in dem prinzessin
diana stirbt die königin der herzen
mit dem tod der queen ist und platz für
die neue königin des britischen
königshauses und wer das ist bestimmt
heutzutage nicht mehr allein die
thronfolge hinter verschlossenen türen
beginnt der kampf um die herzen der
briten kate gegen mögen bild macht den
royalen check wer hat die besseren
chancen auf die krone der herzen
style
ob gala dinner charity event oder
einschulung der kinder die prinzessin
von achtung neuer titel wales ist immer
elegant dezent und klassisch gekleidet
von make up des perms kate kann's
königlich medienmarke liebs modisch
immer wieder sorgt sie für bau auftritte
spart dabei meistens keine kosten
abendessen in new york dafür lässt man
gern um die 5000 euro springen auch vor
ihrem exit ist megan stets glamourös
angezogen modische faux-pas gibt es bei
ihr kaum besonders originell beherzigen
dabei meistens jedoch nicht immer wieder
kopiert sie harrys mutter wie hier bei
jener 1992 in kairo ärgern 2009/10 in
südafrika oder als mégane dreist diesen
look kopiert da jänner 1982 damals
schwanger mit william im grünen mantel
daneben legen schwanger mit archie zum
verwechseln ähnlich das teil modisch
sind sie beide doch kate es steht so
originell und elegant punkt für kate
promifaktor
als ehemalige schauspielerin bringt
morgen auf jeden fall eins mit ins
verregnete königreich den
hollywood-glamour seit mehr als zehn
jahren ist die 41 jährige inzwischen dem
showgeschäft in dieser zeit hat sie sich
ruhm reichtum hart erarbeitet und
freundschaften der extraklasse ob
talkshow meisterin oprah winfrey tennis
wunders serena williams oder sogar
bollywood schauspielerin priyanka chopra
man kennt sie alle die olympiasiegerin
williams ist auch erster gast in meggen
sportcast
kates beste freundinnen
selbstverständlich adelig glamour
schlägt krümmel klarer punkt anmerken
dass familien faktor
kate die super mama mit herz und hingabe
beobachtet die welt nun seit knapp zehn
jahren kate bei der erziehung ihrer
kinder einen tag vor dem todestag der
queen bringt die kleinen zum ersten
schultag alle drei in vornehmer
schuluniform wie es sich für das
königshaus gehört dass es auch weniger
royal zugehen kann zeigt uns prinz louis
bei einer veranstaltung zum
thronjubiläum dieses jahres kate bleibt
beherrscht aber liebevoll ein bisschen
lustig findet sie es auch mit
der queen und allen weiteren
familienmitgliedern des königshauses
paket stets vertraut liebe und würde
voll vor allem mit könig charles und
seiner frau camilla pflegt sie eine enge
bindung immer wieder betont wie wichtig
ihr familie sei doch für die
eingeheiratete familie scheint das nicht
zu gelten kurz nach harrys und merkels
hochzeit brechen die beiden mit der
königsfamilie ziehen weit weg weit nach
kalifornien als sei es damit nicht genug
lassen sie kaum ein interview aus um
weitere intime palast geheimnisse
auszuplaudern und die royale familie
öffentlich an den pranger zu stellen wie
im legendären opera interview auch
kürzlich tritt morgen im interview mit
cut noch einmal nach auch in ihrem neuen
podcast kann man kaum seitenhiebe
vermeiden erst als ich mit meinem mann
zusammen kam verstand ich was es
bedeutet wie eine schwarze frau
behandelt zu werden familiensinn sieht
anders aus streitereien mit bruder
großeltern und urgroßeltern sollte man
im besten fall auch privat austragen
beim wenn es hier um eine
jahrtausendealte tradition geht sorry
mégane auch dieser punkt geht an kate
damit ist kathrin prinzessin von wales
die klare gewinnerin des bild checks wir
verneigen uns vor kate der neuen königin
der herzen
verneigung aber die magie lässt das
natürlich nicht auf sich sitzen das
viele noch nicht in die wertung ein
neues video in hambergen ein herzens
video das zeigt wie sehr der im moment
gekämpft wird um auch ihr herz zu hause
also mitten im großeinsatz
großoffensive auch auf ihr herz schauen
sie wie sie dort in london auf die
trauernden zugeht kann auch mal rein
horchen sie hört nämlich zu den menschen
in diesen momenten und patricia lange
umarmung aber noch ein bisschen schon
wieder musik darunter gelegt damit es
auch ihr herz berührt weil sie nicht
merken fans sind das spaltet ja wirklich
die lager muss man sagen ist mein
teenagern oder team kate aber ist das
jetzt aufgesetzt oder ist das echt
vertriebs ja also
natürlich sind die ganzen momente
inszeniert das ist ja klar
geplant dass sie raus geht aber so haben
wir sie doch noch nicht gesehen oder das
ist doch schon neuer medien in diesem
moment ich gleichzeitig weil das ja
schon immer ihre strategie setzt aufs
herz ich finde das gar nicht so unecht
bei ihr aber es ist natürlich auch
glaube ich bisschen kalkuliert ich hab
sie weiß schon oder sprechen wir mit
julia vilimsky und reporterin in london
die all diese momente miterlebt julia
hat megan dein herz erreicht und
verzeihe noch ein bisschen wichtiger hat
sie die menschen dort vom buckingham
palace die trauernden die
hunderttausenden in großbritannien hat
sie die erreicht
ja so gerne begibt sich ja hier voll und
ganz in die charmeoffensive und
natürlich wir hören solche momente die
gemüter sie schmelzen die herzen das
sind auch die bilder nach denen man
lässt kann man schon sagen gerade in
traurigen stunden es ist ja immer noch
wichtiger auch diese schönen positiven
momente zu sehen und was man sagen kann
es gibt schon klar die zwei lager team
ergänzen kate und auch die
schattenseiten denn wir haben jetzt
gerade diesen positiven moment gesehen
diese innige umarmung diese sehr nah
wahre situation aber es gab auch momente
wo sich tatsächlich eine besucherin ein
royaler fan direkt offensiv von medien
abgewendet hat und ihr praktisch die
hand verweigert hat und medien sehr
professionell ich wenn sie ist eher ein
geübter star ein medienprofi sozusagen
hat das ja gar land gemeistert und nicht
da groß aufhebens gemacht aber auch
dieser moment ging viral und deswegen so
ja man merkt deutlich die zwei
unterschiedlichen teams und ja es bleibt
abzuwarten wie jetzt auch in den
nächsten tagen natürlich mit argusaugen
beobachtet wird ob kate oder medien die
nase vorne haben in dem thema wer
erobert die herzen der menschen und der
royalen fans absolut schulisches gehen
sondern danke dir für deine einschätzung
das wird ein schwieriger kampf und die
brüder müssen sie auch wieder zusammen
kriegen keine einfache aufgabe denn
jetzt du denn lieber um am kai im moment
alle miteinander
das ist die hölle royale strategie nicht
mehr gegen an der kampf ist auch das
falsche wort sondern ein ganz großes
miteinander und werben um die herzen in
der welt ich glaube so habe ich das ja
entfernt ein national erwartet
[Musik]